hey don't forget to check out our
exclusive shirts at anime uproar dot-com
including Eskin or praise the Sun Mele
Otis filled a wrath demon king meliodas
all hailed the King and many more all
the designs are exclusive originals made
by Pro manga artist Cuusoo mati and
every sure you buy help support this
channel
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the latest
developments in the seven deadly sins
story and let me say this right now
without any exaggeration chapter 306 of
the manga has given us some major
historic developments in the story after
this chapter things will never be the
same again I will of course be delving
deep into all of this in the video but
before we get started please remember
this will contain manga spoilers up to
chapter 306 of the seven deadly sins
manga proceed with caution you have been
warned if you enjoy these types of
videos and you want to see more you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell in case you didn't know we are
hosting live discussions of the seven
deadly sins chapters every week
Wednesdays 5 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
on Twitch if you want to hang out and
chat with us live about everything that
happened in that week's chapter follow
us at twitch TV slash anime uproar link
in the description now first things
first am I the only one who while
reading this chapter just kept thinking
where is hawk in one panel we see a
little thing beside Merlin's shoulder
that might be hawk in his miniature form
like the one he ended up in after the
fight with daemon Hendrickson and there
are some little dark smudges that we see
in other panels that might be hawk but
there's just no way to tell for sure
after the events of chapter 305 in which
Hawk attacked the demon king and
distracted him so that the an and bond
could tag-team him into submission I've
been wondering what in the world
happened to him and the fact that it
hasn't been addressed by any of the
other characters is very strange
and if hob just became really small
again wouldn't someone have said hey
guys hawk is super small on top of that
why couldn't Hawk enter melioidosis mind
along with the sins earlier on and why
did the demon king keep calling him a
rare beast and how is all of this tied
to the mother of chaos the fact that no
one addresses or even mentions hawk at
all in this chapter just makes me even
more curious about what exactly happened
to him after his encounter with the Dean
if you have any thoughts or theories
please share them down below because I'm
very curious to see what you guys think
looking at the title of chapter 306 in
the official translation it's called the
end of a long journey and from the look
of it the last stop on this journey was
the act of removing the curses that had
been placed on malleolus and Elizabeth
by the demon king in the supreme deity
but I will get back to that in just a
bit as the demon king is seemingly
defeated the lesser demons who were
attacking Leona's suddenly stop their
attack and begin to retreat now that the
demon king has been defeated and the
threat to the goddess clan has been
eliminated
ludo shell starts to get Vayne oast and
by that I mean he is no longer able to
maintain his physical form and he begins
to disintegrate miele who unlike Ludo
Chell seems fine probably due to the
fact that he was sealed away inside his
real body after the last holy war
because of the whole esta rosa thing
says that the threat of the demon king
is finally gone but Ludo Chell says that
this is naive and he claims that the
fact that the demon king has been
vanquished does not mean that the holy
war is over looter shall calls this the
first small step towards the goddesses
and demons no longer hating each other
and towards the holy war ending for good
we see a lot of character growth in this
chapter from Ludo shell so far we have
known him to be a ruthless Archangel who
wanted to exterminate all the demons and
as someone who took part in destroying
innocent demons who didn't do anything
wrong because he believed that demons
are such horrible creatures that
destroying them is actually doing them a
favor there were a few exceptions to
this type of behavior from New Rochelle
he did show some compassion for people
like his brother Elizabeth and
Hendrickson but overall he was a pretty
ruthless character up to this point
however he now says that he is also sick
of this meaningless holy war and he
appears to be happy that the goddesses
and demons have finally taken this first
step forward as Elizabeth thanks Ludo
shell and mile for risking their lives
to help them Ludo shell disintegrates
and disappears this is actually pretty
sad for my L who just recovered his
memories and realized that he had been
separated from his brother all this time
and now he has to lose him again I am
very curious to see what mile is going
to do with his life from now on he is no
longer a demon he doesn't have his
brother he has all these regrets about
the horrible things he has done as esta
rosa and as a right now
the other goddesses still don't have
their physical body so in some ways he
is pretty alone but anyway even though
the demon king has seemingly been
defeated and everyone is finally
reunited including all the sins and
malleolus in his normal form there is
still the matter of Elizabeth's curse
and she now has only one day before the
curse activates Elizabeth says that she
doesn't mind as long as everyone is okay
in Mellie Otis is back to his normal
self
after all she will still keep
reincarnating so she will eventually see
everyone again but surprisingly in that
moment Mellie Otis says that he knows
how to break the curse and that he
somehow gained enough power to do it as
he was escaping purgatory I am assuming
that this is related to Mellie Otis's
original power finally awakening the
same original power that the demon king
feared and that he referred to as the
source of destruction if Mellie Otis's
original power is the source of
destruction and it is tied to the idea
of destroying then it would make sense
that curses are one of the things that
this power can destroy Merlyn then casts
a spell that reveals the curse is
affecting malleolus and Elizabeth and
they take on a visible form as the
curses appear Mellie Otis seemingly
activates a new form which appears very
similar to the demon Kings form and he
was in meliodas body with the difference
being that Mellie Otis is not in the
adult form that the demon king was in
but just looks like his normal self with
some extra accessories at this time
Mellie Otis and Elizabeth have a
beautiful emotional moment where she
asks him if he will still go on loving
her forever even after the curses are
broken and Mellie Otis in his classic
fun-loving and playful style says that
of course he will he will love her until
she gets sick of him I have to say that
I absolutely loved this moment it seems
to capture the personalities of both
Elizabeth and Ally Otis perfectly and it
really brings out the things that we
love about these characters and their
relationship meliodas proceeds to
destroy the curses and they dissipate
Mellie Otis says that now their long
journey is finally finished
but Elizabeth says that no it's only
just begun the chapter ends as the sins
decide to head back to Leona's and the
captions on the side of the final page
say that now the 3,000 year journey
heads towards its
final stop we also learned that the next
chapter is called epilogue 1 and the
word epilogue normally refers to a
section at the very end of a book so
these are some pretty clear indications
that the seven deadly sins manga may be
ending within the next few weeks we can
assume that because the next chapter is
called epilogue 1 there will be at least
one more epilogue chapter in which we
will get to see the aftermath of the
battle and how everyone will go on with
their lives from here on out
kind of like the photographs at the end
of Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood in
which we briefly see what happens after
Idi al Winry and the rest get older and
continue to live their lives presumably
happily ever after so is this the end
are we really just two or three chapters
away from the end of the entire story
there are some unresolved questions in
this chapter
ludo shel says that this is only one
small step towards ending the holy war
implying that it isn't over yet and
Elizabeth says that this is just the
beginning of their journey we also don't
know what's going on with hawk or the
supreme deity or the mother of chaos but
the fact that the next chapter is called
epilogue one clearly implies that the
story is almost over and now we're just
going to see a brief after word of what
happens after the big battle against the
demon king is it possible that the brief
statements by New Rochelle and Elizabeth
were clues that even after this part of
the story ends the manga will keep going
or there will be a spin-off or a sequel
/ part 2 of the manga after a break kind
of like Naruto part 2 aka Naruto
Shippuden or were the words by Ludo
Chell and Elizabeth merely symbolic
referring to the fact that the lives and
adventures of these characters will
continue but we won't get to see them
because the main series is over in the
very last panel of the chapter we see
some very interesting lights but we
don't know if these lights are just
supposed to represent a brighter future
or stars in the sky or maybe something
more important like for example the
celestial realm opening and the supreme
deity emerging just when it looked like
everything else was resolved but any
ideas about these lights being more than
just lights is only speculation at this
point personally I don't know what to
think about the end of the series the
seven deadly sins manga is definitely
very successful and it is consistently
in the top 10 selling manga and the fact
that last year in 2018 we had
the season 2 of the anime come out and
the prisoners of the sky movie indicates
that the seven deadly sins franchise is
definitely profitable the fact that the
anime is distributed as a Netflix
original outside of Japan is also a big
deal because Netflix has been investing
increasingly large amounts of money into
its anime properties so money and
profitability are definitely not the
issue and if the manga con acaba Suzuki
wanted to continue the seven deadly sins
I am sure that he could do it without
any problem the only issue that I see is
whether naka bouzouki himself still
wants to keep writing about the seven
deadly sins or whether he wants to take
a break or maybe move on to something
else
creative work is very challenging and if
artists are not in the right creative
space to continue a work the quality of
that work is sure to suffer so at the
end of the day it will be all up to the
Creator naka ba Suzuki himself and
that's the way it should be
yes we've grown to love these characters
and this story and there are many
unsolved mysteries in the series that I
would love to see explored for at least
like 200 more chapters but if the story
does and now I will still be content
thanks to the seven deadly sins we've
gotten to know some incredible
characters like bon meliodas Eskin or
Merlyn Kings eldritch my girl derriere
II Hawk and so many more these last few
arts of the manga have been absolute
fire I've loved every second of it and
if it all ends on such a high note then
all I can say is thank you naka but
tsudzuki for all your hard work thank
you for all the memories and I wish you
all the best in all your future projects
and here at Anime uproar we will
definitely be following all the latest
updates about the seven deadly sins and
any future projects that knockabout
Suzuki might be involved in as soon as
we have confirmed news about either the
seven deadly sins anime or manga we will
inform you here on the channel and if
you want to be the first to know about
any such news like when we have an
official confirmation for the release
date of the new season of the anime
follow us on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar we will keep you posted
about everything there let me know what
you guys thought about Chapter 306 and
about where the story is heading now is
it really over and if so how do you
think it will end also if this story
doesn't end or there is some sort of
spin-off or sequel what do you think
will be the plotline for
this continuation what new adventures
will the sins go on and what potential
future villains will they have to face
give me your thoughts down in the
comments below I always love hearing
from you all so what do you think about
Mele Otis's new form does this mean that
he has become the new demon king or is
that just a manifestation of his
original power if you feel that videos
like this one provide value for you and
you want to support more you can check
out our patreon we recently revamped the
whole thing a big thank you to all of
the patrons supporting us right now
including our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only Gilgamesh and keelon and
also are the one to your patrons the
ones who stand above all clans including
a seventeen FF DP lil lady KD and Maddie
Mac 239 even donating a single dollar
will give you access to our special page
and only discord and you will see your
name appear in our videos so please if
you're interested check us out linked in
the description as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]